[Music]
45 seconds of incredible ogos sure just
about the raddest logos I've ever seen
but logos nonetheless agent rick dicker
interrogating rick dicker this is a
clever way to catch the audience up on
the end of a movie that occurred 14
years prior but it's still under minor
overkill i mean the scene basically
reinforces to the public that they need
the Incredibles version of the sokovia
accords but the character otherwise
really has nothing to do with the plot
also it took 14 years for a sequel to
this movie believe me
hey I thought that was just for
anniversaries and other special
occasions Bob why didn't they call this
movie The Incredibles 2 considering the
first movie was The Incredibles what did
Sean Parker come in and tell Brad Birds
specifically to drop the vote this is
almost my favorite part I think he's
about to fight the Balrog that's correct
movies telling me that everyone survives
this mass bombing I don't care what
these jackhammer fists are made of given
mr. incredible super strength there is
no way this is a fight at all if you
told me that the next Incredibles movie
would also be in adventures in
babysitting sequel I don't think I would
have believed you
yeah they use ice monorail where these
cars even on the road it's impossible to
miss the giant ass sentient drill that's
been on the road for several minutes let
alone all the quakes it's been causing
this is a great save by stretch mount
strong and all but it sure is a good
thing that the passenger had the
split-second reflexes and foresight to
get her car door open even though there
was no way she could have known it would
help we didn't start this fight well you
didn't finish it even you stopped the
Underminer from inflicting more damage
she's got damn it I'm sick of this human
outrage over superheroes saving everyone
bull yes the original movie was the
first to do it and it's probably done
least defensively in this franchise but
you think Incredibles 2 would have moved
on from using a story point that Batman
V Superman had already drilled into the
ground I'm done I know they had to
replace bud lucky for this character and
it's not like Jonathan banks doesn't
have a great voice but does he always
have to play the tired ex-cop that's too
old for this we talked about this you're
not old enough to decide about these
things this is another plot point that I
thought was resolved in the last movie
didn't they realize that they all needed
each other to take down a threat and
that was even the reason they all put on
their masks from the Underminer showed
up so movies great but it definitely
does replay the hits a lot you know
where my suit and ties are burned up
when the judge you know the cops were
just talking about the banks being
insured and Bob used to work in
insurance so why don't the pars have any
coverage on their house have to rely on
dicker to set them up wasn't nationwide
around in the 1960s I know the drill why
is violet just suspicious now with the
boots when the super suits were clearly
visible at the top of the jackets the
whole time father was so proud that I
was even remotely connected to you guys
he was your top supporter give him the
stuff Winston rattles off here that
daddy'd ever endeavoured to help the
supers when they already know who he
wants an eccentric billionaire is
interested in superheroes because his
parents were shot and killed by a
seemingly random act of violence
sounds familiar I mean sounds familiar I
mean that's Batman him back also what
the these asshole robbers made it all
the way inside the house of what has to
be one of the richer people in the
country saw him on the superhero phone
that he showed it off to everyone but
still couldn't keep their shooting
boners from going off also also you
could say that the robbers were
emboldened because the supers were just
banned but if they knew that how to demo
not know that I'm just saying this crux
of the plot narrative is super thin or
dad could have taken mom to the safe
room as soon as
he knew there was fried agree strongly
week they also had a safe room why
didn't he install the super phones and
next if the Dever dad had any sense of
phone placement he'd have saved
countless lives
super rights and his daughters pending
villainy she's good she really a credit
to her about mr. incredibly sexist now
you get the offer of a lifetime and you
don't know this is an important
discussion at all but why don't they
back at the pool having it isn't this a
one room set up even if the kids are in
a separate room the walls have gotta be
finished around here why is the remote
for every single feature for this room
all the way upstairs and completely out
of reach also there is no way that
remote contains enough buttons to do all
that the dash was able to do great
there's a water opening directly under
the couch this is about the stupidest
moat placement in the history of moat
placements proposed by me no sugar bombs
on my watch but why were they just right
out there and they opened it it's not
like Helen put them out there she's the
one pushing everyone to be healthy so
mom is going out illegally to explain
why she shouldn't be illegal violet
would be super at cinemasins
I know what's Pixar and all but as
Shakespeare said a poop joke by any
other name would smell as poop or
something dude there's a lot of
pedestrian traffic behind Helen here but
nobody even gives a passing glance to an
act of illegal superhero in costume
Elastigirl is able to do this at top
speed in a new motorcycle in an
unfamiliar city with the moment's notice
and she's now stretching my credulity
further than her body can reach and just
like that Bradbury proves he's still a
god of animated action clever touches
like a splitting bike for a stretchy
super camera angles that emphasize the
craziness of the clothes movements
without ever losing the overall
geography at the scene total shots of
pure glorious cinematic adrenaline
courts throughout this movie and I
couldn't stop myself from taking a few
sins off if I wanted to didn't Helen
just say that the bike was electric that
she juice it up with a tank full of
flammable diesel just for old times sake
honey why are you don't
Wow ain't that convenient all the Bob's
kids are having very age-specific issues
on the first night he's watching them
all so why didn't Bob know that violet
was set up to be stood up by Tony on the
date even if he didn't specifically ask
Rick Ehrmantraut to take care of Tony's
memory he had to know something would be
done right let me tell you something I'm
about to take a sin off for this raccoon
Jack Jack fight because it's goddamn
glorious but before we do this I've got
to send the fact that the raccoons there
at all considering that the Parrs just
moved in and wouldn't produced enough
trash to get its attention
okay now that that's out of the way
begin Jack Jack versus the rock racks
section is like Pixar somehow snuck one
of its best short films into a larger
film and still had it make complete
sense as part of the story having said
that this raccoon survives all day I was
cool letting the raccoon be a little
more human than seems likely because you
know cartoons got a cartoon but when you
have the vermin purposely tip over the
grill because it somehow knows the ash
will put out the flame you'll officially
push me over the hitch that's fantastic
honey on your first night I get that we
have to establish a bit of a strain on
the relationship between Bob and Helen
here but ultimately it plays a very
small role in this movie other than to
prove how badass the females in this
story are we already knew that trust me
let's move on to more that Jack Jack if
you forget and forget what how did
remove only the parts of Tony's memory
that involved violet of all the
technology presented in this franchise
shouldn't this be one of the most
powerful yeah ready for you hey stretch
Oleg hey we'll handle the stretching for
buns around here miss definitely will
end up being the surprise villain in
this movie we are controlled by squeeze
if Helen instinctively knows not to look
at the screen why couldn't she just
reach out and move the monitor out of
chad's eyesight apparently as soon as
the stimulus is removed everyone's all
good maybe try that before resorting to
slapping the dude in the face why are
there king regular-ass screens on the
panel of a helicopter in 1962 pretty
sure even the top models only had like
four sets of analog dials that barely
worked
Nana sure are a lot of unoccupied
buildings for Helen to crash things into
in this city in support of you what is
your sign say
well who is this Stepford daughter
and why did she make this sign I don't
look hypnotized and I've never seen
again in the movie so again I say what
the hell alright stop talking shower
this is somehow a combination of the
pronoun game and a you better take a
look at this cliche and it's definitely
doubly annoying the other supers are
right in the next room I'm called brick
nice to meet you
brick they were right in the middle of
the introductions and there aren't many
supers here so why did they start the
party before they all met dhikr dhikr I
don't even know her sorry about that
what I meant to say was guy wears a
Hawaiian shirt and has a drink with a
little umbrella to symbolize retirement
even though he's not even on vacation
yet cliche what do you know about Tony
not much popular play sports music
parents on the happy platter kid works
there part-time Jesus what qualifies is
knowing a lot about a subject the
frequency of their bowel movements seems
like Dicker's got a ton of useful
information immediately at his
fingertips given the sheer amount of
wiring and satellite antenna on this
building which would be very weird in
1962 how has this place not been
investigated at all before now this
apartment is located in a high-rise
building it requires massive exposition
of whatever the tenant and/or it's evil
hypnotic Overlord is plotting it's in
the Charter and everything also look I
know we're in a movie that uses a lot of
possibly anachronistic technology but
maglev trains work implemented way after
1962 like they only started functional
use in the 1980s I'm not saying it
didn't give us a terrific action
sequence but did it have to use this
device
welcome to the UPS I forgot my own super
powers portion of today's film what
Elastigirl ever run after anyone when
she could just stretch out and catch
them especially if they're this close
your tracker worked like a charm Evelyn
man this is so annoying
Helen's been shown to be much more
thoughtful than this and she knows
someone's been using hypnosis for
nefarious purposes given this dude's
response she doesn't even give the idea
that he's not screens labor a second
thought until much later also screens
labor is a badass-looking villain and
the fact that he's given like 10 seconds
of actual screen time definitely
qualifies as a sin beyond repair they
said it was destroyed they said it was
that's my car never pronoun game an
anger bomb never pronoun game and anger
yes it does and from any distance and
without a millisecond of lag because
apparently each remote comes
pre-installed with a handy convenience
chip I love the scene but I simply can't
ignore dashes blood lost here I mean he
sees it's a crowded fucking room I've
got to succeed
so she can succeed so we can't succeed
Bob Bob clearly shows how committed he
is to this funny but ultimately boring B
story put one red thing in a load of
whites no everything's pink this list of
bad parenting cliches reminds me that
Helens being well paid for her exploits
right I have to have a living wage to
afford food and services and if it's
coming from Dever then you're damn sure
it's a lot so even though Bob's trying
to be a super dad here let me send the
laundry out so Jack Jack has all the
powers right like he's better than
Superman he can travel the different
dimensions for long periods of time fly
shoot lasers do beast mode multiply grow
to any size catch fire I'm sure whatever
else is needed for comedic effect in
this movie my point is this should be a
bigger deal he has all the powers his
reign was short huh and not suspiciously
so at all huh huh just now at a
worldwide summit leaders from more than
a hundred of the world's top countries
have agreed to make superheroes legal
again it's been a couple weeks
pretty sure changing laws takes a bit
more time and bureaucracy than that I
mean wheat is still illegal in most of
the country and the majority of
Americans change their mind on that
during the Lebowski administration also
damn they got those super powerful
people together faster than the dinosaur
auction and Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom what the pizza guy is really a
pizza guy but it was controlled by the
strange built into one class
you are good so you're telling me the
character who always seemed a little too
nonchalant and played into the female
narrative and whose name could actually
be pronounced evil endeavour was the bad
guy consider me shocked shocked I say
also that's all it takes everyone didn't
even hit a button or do anything other
than put the glasses on which were
clearly not functioning before these
things aren't just technological marvels
they're downright magic I worked in a
creative diva so how did I get Jack Jack
all domesticated then bob was out
overnight but the baby also slept so she
whipped his ass into shape in like five
hours
I would resist the temptation to stretch
the temperature around you is well below
freezing so one last a girl's kryptonite
is the entire month of January since
what is that a thing I'm using the
technology to destroy people's trust in
it like I'm using superheroes Wow seems
like we arrived at the unnecessary
villainous exposition cliche a little
too quick eh
trust me it's not the last time that
it'll feel like the movies rushing to
resolve all the plot lines like even
Tony comes back into the picture
superheroes keep us weak goddammit this
movie is better than having the villain
turn full villain as soon as she's found
out if he was always this fucking
unhinged how'd she keep it together for
so long
quick question has anyone tried maybe
closing their eyes she's not exactly
clockwork orange' in their eyelids or
anything
I mean Helen now knows how this works
use a thing see that that's a current
readable click see the readout so Edna
invented created and manufactured this
piece of technology the perfectly reeds
and handles every single one of Jack
Jack's powers in one night and we're
just gonna Yatta Yatta it that is some
next-level incredible already have a
mask with high protection does that
really have no effect on this immediate
hypnosis he's messed really pissed me
off by the way hello hey sure did seem
like the villains were hot on abducting
these kids a second ago but apparently
immediately abandon any pursuit but we
got frozen bring it to the ship at dev
tech immediately can I just get an
instruction booklet on exactly how this
hypno tech works I mean what the pizza
guy it was insinuated his actions were
being directly controlled but these guys
seem like independent contractors who
still have to be given verbal
instructions so which is it I have to
send this movement for being
preposterous ly convenient but I'm also
smiling too hard at how awesome it is
also yes this moment is awesome but -
forget he could run on water I thought
that was very well established in the
first movie at least he could catch the
boat wait who's gonna watch seriously
we're still doing the whole baby-sitters
club superhero edition thing it's the
whole point of this movie actually about
the difficulty in procuring decent child
care
I like void a lot and she's got some
dope-ass powers but the ability to track
violet to this exact location after
seeing like 10 steps from the dirt
cannot be one of them
also this fight is badass but power all
supers fully trained martial artists
like I get how Elastigirl and mr.
incredible who've been doing this for
years are capable in a fight but here's
teenage violet throwing haymakers at
Boyd who's apparently downloaded the
kung-fu program from the matrix nobody
has the audacity to show us that which
way does the battery go twins fluffy
earbud man and captain crochet without
giving us any clue with their powers
maybe
I know I'm pointing out a lot of cliches
in this movie but it's got a surprising
amount I mean did we really need this
waiting on the elevator listening to
music during an action scene redo I know
alright seems like the plan dependence
of those goggles staying perfectly in
place on every superhero would be a
problem even though they've somehow
stayed on place during all sorts of
violent fights and scuffles how could I
be mad and proud until the next movie
when I tried you for using your
superpowers again for no reason but for
now let's hug this out casual shooting
of baby lasers toward your hostage
brother is casual hey you did this can
you undo it you want me to crush yes or
if you're really going to stick with
this nonsense about not being able to
uncrushed things you could just crush it
even further so that mr. incredible can
get through or since he's been shown to
have pretty immense superpowers he could
probably just bust his way through it
himself
reflux could melt it away or about a
hundred other different ways that you
could just get to the engine room
quickly and immediately stop this boat
but climax s to climax I guess the
reputations of superheroes are brilliant
as are the chances everyone makes it out
of this situation considering she's
spouting yet another unnecessary
villainous exposition cliche this works
[Music]
considering this plane is going to
continue its descent directly into the
ocean what exactly did pushing the
autopilot do awesome I'm sure there was
no one on that busy coastal Street of
this populous city on a very
nice-looking day that's not dead
the insinuation here is that they all
change into their super suits now right
in the car I'm just saying growing up in
the power family must be super awkward
this contract is boy Jordan fades back
swoosh
[Music]
burnin here's got a job Bernie's got
prospects
he's bona fide what are you I'll tell
you what I am
I'm the paterfamilias and you can't
marry him I can't I am and I will
tomorrow
I am called Griff nice to meet you brick
people seem to like me because I am
polite and I'm rarely late our
superheroes allowed to drink on duty I'm
looking at porn are you scared I bet
you're glad having your old pal
spider-man showed up in the elevator the
one you weren't much help I don't owe
you a damn thing all of this falling
apart like this is on you you got the
address I'll meet you guys there go in
our super suit when you are a man
sometimes you wear stretchy pants in
your room
it's for fun my work is done here didn't
I hello uh hello in other news the prime
minister of Sweden visited Washington
today and my tiny little nipples went to
France I eat done dirty crap lightning
okay look great but what are you doing
with that thing